hey youtubers is Charlie so we've just
confirmed that we're gonna be seeing new
Justice League footage really soon they
didn't say exactly which day but there
are a couple solid bets
just because fantastic beasts another
big Warner Brothers franchise which is
gonna get like five movies is coming out
this weekend and Ben Affleck has a big
movie coming out this December during
Christmas weekend so I'll explain that
and talk about the death of Superman
because we are one year away from
Justice League coming out it's coming
out November 17th so like literally this
day next year which is also coinciding
with the 25th anniversary of the death
of Superman in comics what a coincidence
so Justice League footage here's what we
know fantastic beasts is being released
this weekend so if we do not see a new
Justice League trailer tomorrow or in
the next couple of days like next
Tuesday then I would plan for it to drop
with Ben Affleck's movie at the end of
the year that movie is called live by
night he just plays this really badass
gangster it's set during Prohibition era
it stars Zoe Saldana who's Gamora
so that's being released like literally
on Christmas Day December 25th so a lot
of you remember that there was a rumor
earlier this year that we were gonna get
a whole bunch of trailers on a bunch of
days in the next couple of months
so one of those was the Justice League
trailer it was supposed to drop around
that December 25th date so my bet is is
that they're attaching some Justice
League Batman footage to another Batman
related film so to speak but one of the
cool things that's different now about
the way Studios dropped trailers then
say even like a couple years ago is that
they'll drop like a really quick teaser
or a picture or they have a social media
account that'll just start posting weird
stuff that will lead up to them dropping
footage so like way back in the day all
they would do is just like drop the one
trailer and that's it they wouldn't do
anything else but now because like all
the different social media platforms
you'll start to see like weird stuff
happen on their accounts before they
actually do something really big so
it'll actually be a little bit easier to
know
when it's gonna drop when we get within
like a week of it so because we still
haven't seen a whole lot about it I'm
just planning for that Christmas weekend
and we're still like a long ways off
from hearing about the Batman movie but
I know a lot of you are asking about the
rumor that the script was trash like
there was like somebody in Hollywood who
is saying that there was a lot of
problems with the Batman script in the
studio supposedly didn't care about it
because they knew they would make so
much money on it internationally in the
reason that I didn't do a video for that
is just like I waited literally waited a
day to do a video for it just to explain
what was going on in the person who was
trashing the script came out and
profusely apologized probably because he
was worried that Ben Affleck would come
to his house and punch him in the face
or that the studio would never work with
him again because the person was Bret
Easton Ellis who's actually been
directing like one of the YouTube read
original series so that gives you an
idea for like his current status in
Hollywood he's directing youtubers so
he's not someone inside the Warner
Brothers circle of trust he's not inside
the Batman circle so he hasn't read the
script and he was really just reporting
some gossip that he heard secondhand
from another person who was also
probably not in the note so the whole
thing was just a bunch of garbage don't
worry about it the Batman movie is fine
I think that's part of the reason why we
haven't seen geoff johns be more active
on social like every once in a while
he'll post something but he's actually
been pretty quiet this past year but
mostly I think that's because he and his
wife had a baby and because he's now in
charge of all these DC films meaning
that he probably never sleeps but
supposedly like this new Justice League
footage the stuff that's going to be
different from previous Justice League
trailers is that it'll just feature a
whole lot more Aquaman because everybody
behind the scenes is saying that Jason
Momoa is just killing it which sounds
about right
especially from the stuff that we've
seen so far like he looks like he's
having more fun than anybody else on
that film set so whatever ends up
happening I will totally do a video the
minute we find out exactly when we're
getting new footage and what's going to
be in it
so in related news you probably know
that they're doing a live-action Justice
League dark film Guillermo del Toro was
originally gonna do the whole thing
himself now he's still on as a producer
but they did just release a new trailer
for the animated Justice League dark
which stars Matt Ryan as Constantine and
Batman's in it so I'll just play that
trailer here and then I'll talk a little
bit about what's going on with that
these crimes were committed by
law-abiding citizens they all have seen
nightmare visions before hand the same
pattern is repeating around the world so
there could be an overriding paranormal
element are you talking about magic that
we have to find John Constantine
into the house
come on it's a dream team you mean
Zatanna Batman maybe even a Justice
League let's take a walk on the dark
side then Swamp Thing you dare threaten
the green let's do this
we'll get off
your life is a patchwork of blackness
with no time for joy how do you cope
with it I have a butler so as you guys
can see Jason O'Mara who's currently on
agents of shield is doing Batman Matt
Ryan is doing Constantine which I
thought was really cool when we found
out about that back during comic-con but
if you're not familiar with Justice
League dark it's basically like a
Justice League team-up based of the
Magic characters in the DC Universe they
did like a big new 52 title now they're
kind of spinning it into a live-action
thing but they have this cool movie
coming too so the animated team in this
movie is Constantine Batman Zatanna
Ettrick and the demon Superman and
Wonder Woman are also in it but
obviously they're not part of Justice
League dark they're part of the regular
Justice League team just like Batman
Ritchie Simpson who is a Hellblazer
character he kind of comes with
Constantine Felix Faust who's one of the
villains of Justice League dark then
destiny who's actually being played by
Alfred Molina he's actually character
from The Sandman comics Neil Gaiman's
Sandman and then Swamp Thing who's like
one of the weirdest coolest characters
that I've always been hoping that they'd
work into the live-action universe
eventually but he was a big part of that
in the comics and then Black Orchid so
it's just like a really weird cast of
characters in a really fun storyline
that'll kind of get you prepped for
live-action Justice League dark in a
couple years but that's a little further
off so once we get through the
live-action regular Justice League movie
we'll probably hear more about that so
the regular movies I think Warner
Brothers just wants people to focus on
the current justice league roster
then they'll weave in more magic based
weird stuff with Justice League dark but
this movie the animated movie is coming
out January 24th on video on demand and
then the DVD is dropping February 7 so
let me know what you guys think about
live-action Justice League in
live-action Justice League dark do you
think they'll actually end up doing it
or do you think it'll just get postponed
indefinitely because they've been
talking about doing a Justice League
dark movie for a long time now like
Guillermo del Toro worked his ass off
for like the last ten years
to
try and get something going but either
way new legends of tomorrow posting
tonight there is a DC giveaway that's
going on all you have to do to enter is
be subscriber leave a comment on this
video so I'll post that video after the
episode airs tonight where you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
like the big behind-the-scenes Justice
League trailer and you can click here
for the trailer for the big four night
TV crossover thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight